what's up everyone welcome to gamespot
we are here with the unboxing for
destiny the taken King the newest
expansion which comes a week after patch
2 point 0 so a lot of things are
changing and people who pre-order the
collector's edition you know like
physical case at least have a few extra
things in terms of what you're getting
outside of the game kind of a good
looking box there's an open side thing
here somewhere in the rubble of our
former glory wise a key to our survival
or perhaps it lies within no matter it
is yours by right claim it so in true
destiny fashion it's always pretty
cryptic stuff so you have the tin case
here this is sort of like halo tues
collector's edition if you remember that
which Bungie also did you have all your
codes in here for the in-game stuff
which we'll get to shortly of course
there's also a book as often as a case
of these things says insula they saw
Aria on it don't know what that means
but there's a tree on the back which
kind of like the emblem which people
have already figured out on reddit there
is the thing with a collector edition
there is a map which comes with it which
is right here inside these this
hollowed-out book and it's sort of a
cipher so like kind of coordinating
letters and numbers between each other
and apparently people have already
figured out that there is in game stuff
you could find based on this information
that will give you emblems and i'm not
sure what else because i think it's a
seven-part thing it's giving you
coordinates like 43 degrees west 56
degrees north says start at the crest
ship begin observations and proceed etc
there's like a dial here and supposedly
this whole Diaries supposed to be
written by Kade the Vanguard
quartermaster a few things written
throughout here as well as a strange
coin real life strange coins kind of
heavy it's like three pounds or so
probably not that heavy I'm not good at
estimating that stuff but these are the
things you use for deserve of course in
the weekends but Kate himself kind of
talking with treasure island it's just
first chapter of Treasure Island which I
guess they're kind of drawing parallels
with destiny because
Treasure Island was a sci-fi multiplayer
novel but anyway there's more maps here
so get that with the collector's edition
and I'm sure that's a picture of the in
game hunter cloak which you'll be able
to unlock as soon as you put in the code
each class is getting a specific class
item so hunter cloak warlock bonds and
the titan yeah the titan skirt but
anyway then you have a few other things
in here which I'm sure somehow relate to
this cipher that people will have to
figure out its Bungie so of course they
always do things in 7s like the seven
pillars in Halo just that kind of stuff
in the vanguard logo on here there's
also a couple cards and then as well as
text mechanic a patch kind of creepy
it's like a longhorn skull and there's
just this earth sticker with a little
destiny logo on it as well as something
else i think is supposedly written by
Kade yeah here you are and what you're
holding in your hands this book that's
mine and it's precious to me don't sweat
it you can read here then it's sign you
know where to find me Kade 6 the hunter
vanguard there's one more thing we're a
picture of it looks like Saturn but
there are other ringed planets I'm not
sure which one it would make sense to be
Saturn because taken king is set on the
Dreadnought which is in the rings of
Saturn dread not being the new area
where you can go in the 10k thinking
releases a 2 a.m. tuesday September 15th
get new story new cinematic new strikes
and then of course it kind of the patch
revamped the light level and everything
you'll be able to go up to level 40 now
new emotes which will be releasing with
the collector edition if you have it
there's like a dance one it's based on
each subclass the hunter does this kind
of the Night Stalker bow and then goes
into a sprinkler he's a much better
dancer than me so I'll embarrass myself
with that but uh you know Titan and the
Warlock also have their own handy
shaders will also be showing you there's
a each class gets a shader it's kind of
a purple one for the hunters plus the
in-game haka early access weapons which
it's
going to be live with the taken King
tonight as well anyway thanks for coming
to gamespot and check back throughout
the week for more coverage on the taken
King and we'll see you there